[Música]
nuevamente hablamos de economía en
directo américa de francia el 24 àngel a
blandón en este estudio de directo
américa daniela vamos a hablar a vamos a
empezar esta crónica de economía con la
visita de nancy pelosi taiwán que
también por supuesto tiene todas las
consecuencias económicas posibles claro
que si ya empezaron veremos hasta dónde
llegan estas consecuencias pero por
ahora china lo que hizo fue bloquear las
importaciones de cítricos y de pescado
desde taiwán como represalia los medios
locales chinos como el 'global times'
también informaron que la agencia de
aduanas bloqueó las importaciones de
galletas y de otros productos
alimenticios de más de 100 proveedores
taiwaneses desde un día antes de la
llegada de pelosi pero de pelosi pero
esto no esto es apenas una pequeña
porción de una relación comercial
binacional de más de 300.000 millones de
dólares anuales que solamente el año
pasado creció en una cuarta parte a
pesar de que beijing y taipei no tengan
relaciones formales diplomáticas por lo
menos
hay viento e interrumpir las
importaciones de chips que representan
una tercera parte de este comercio y que
necesita en sus fábricas para ensamblar
teléfonos inteligentes y otros productos
electrónicos hasta carros inclusive
taiwaneses de responsable de más de la
mitad del suministro mundial de estos
semiconductores esquivó las sanciones
van digamos hasta donde no le perjudica
el otro por es que en rusia no le
exactamente risa alemania me quito la
palabra de la boca pero vamos a hablar
entonces ahora de nuestra región danny
porque la protesta de en panamá también
dejaron ver sus problemas económicos
así es raúl de los estudiantes de panamá
volvieron a las aulas el martes
después de que los docentes pusieran fin
a una vuelta que desencadenó estas
masivas protestas de las que hemos
venido hablando durante varias semanas
las manifestaciones desnudaron la
verdadera situación económica en un país
poco acostumbrado a protestar que son la
desigualdad y la pobreza rural entre
otras nuestro corresponsal local
zurbarán preparó el siguiente informe
es muy común que en este hogar la única
comida al día sea un plato de arroz
maría y su esposo no tienen un trabajo
formal y con siete hijos que mantener la
alimentación el pago del transporte son
las principales prioridades en el
presupuesto del hogar
si da para el pasaje de ellos no da para
la comida si da para la comida el día
siguiente nada para pasar ya russel
quizás brilla además de sufrir por el
alto costo de los alimentos como mariah
también vive el drama de no contar con
una escuela cercana para su hija quien
debe tomar tres vehículos en un trayecto
de dos horas diarias para poder estudiar
si tú no tienen dinero tiene que ser el
caminar
tienes que ser caminando y si eres una
madre soltera o un padre soltero
y trabaja en tu diario
el día que no lleven a para tu casa que
van a comer tú sí insuficientes escuelas
y falta de acceso a los alimentos son
dos factores que afectan a los pobres de
panamá que según el banco mundial en
2020 representaban cerca del 15 por
ciento de la población aunque el
crecimiento económico fue de 15.3 por
ciento los analistas consideran que la
corrupción limita las inversiones en
servicios públicos e incluso dificulta
que se asigna el 6% del pib para la
educación
solicitado por los sectores que están en
conflicto ahora tenemos entonces en
ciernes acuerdos diálogos que a lo mejor
van a obligar al país endeudarse tanto
más entonces la infraestructura que
había sido quizás la esperanza el
desarrollo me refiero de carreteras el
puente el cuarto puente sobre el canal
de panamá y demás ahora a lo mejor se
van a ver pues tirados duramente no
haber tanto recursos porque los recursos
son limitados mientras maría jaruzelski
se intentan enfrentar las carencias del
día a día el gobierno trabaja en un
recién creado instituto de planificación
y hace frente a las demandas de las
organizaciones sociales que se
encuentran en la mesa de diálogo para
cerrar una etapa de protestas que aún no
tiene fecha de caducidad
daniele si seguimos hablando de nuestra
región porque cuba sigue flexibilizando
la entrada de productos del extranjero
si raúl vez esta isla ha venido tomando
distintas medidas para hacer más
permisivo el en el el ingreso de
productos a la zona por ejemplo lo que
intentan es aflojar la presión por el
encarecimiento de algunos productos
básicos justamente después de las
masivas protestas de hace un año el
gobierno de miguel díaz canel había
anunciado que levantaría las
restricciones para que los viajeros
pudieran ingresar alimentos medicinas y
productos de higiene en una cantidad
limitada sin pagar derechos de aduana
pues el más reciente anuncio al respecto
tiene que ver con que los viajeros
podrán ingresar carnes en conserva
también leche líquida ultra pasteurizada
de hasta 13 países distintos también se
redujo el impuesto aduanero del 100 al
30 por ciento en envíos valorados en más
de 30 dólares y hasta 200 dólares
también se duplicará el límite de
importación de 10 kilogramos a 20
kilogramos todas estas que varía según
el artículo van dirigidas a
importaciones no comerciales de
productos que van desde carnes hasta
electrodomésticos teléfonos celulares
bicicletas entre otros y según el
ministerio de agricultura empezarán a
regir desde el 15 de agosto indicadores
económicos danny cómo se mueven los
mercados raúl al alza se mueven hoy los
mercados por fin una buena noticia lo
hace en signos positivos siguiendo los
pasos de asia aunque están muy
pendientes de las tensiones diplomáticas
entre china y eeuu esto por la visita de
nancy pelosi a taiwán en europa por su
parte los mercados operan al alza los
precios del petróleo también suben están
impulsados raúl por la decisión de la
opep más que es el grupo de países
exportadores más sus aliados liderados
por rusia de aumentar en apenas 100 mil
barriles adicionales la oferta de
petróleo desde septiembre porque es tan
bajita esta cifra a raúl porque es que
el mundo consume 100 millones de
barriles al día y ellos están soltando
100 mil barriles que realmente no van a
hacer mucho esto es un nivel mucho menor
al que estaba esperando el mercado por
eso los precios están al alza danny que
nos trae como cifra del día
23% o 780 empleados en esta cifra
reducirá su fuerza laboral la plataforma
de trading para principiantes robin hood
esto debido al mal desempeño del mercado
accionario le doy dos ejemplos bitcoin
vale apenas un tercio de lo que costaba
hace unos meses y wall street había
llegado a bajar hasta un 20 por ciento
en lo corrido de este año y como esos
son los mercados favoritos de los
clientes de robin hood pues el número de
usuarios hoy es de 14 millones y hace un
año era de 21 millones así que la
empresa decide recortar ya había hecho
un reglamento inclusive a comienzos de
este año
danny como siempre gracias a por toda la
información económica mañana por
supuesto más economía que en directo
américa la despidió para pasar a saludar
en méndez para hablar de deportes